[Music]
well the government shutdown is ended
for the moment temporarily but the
battle over a border wall continues the
speaker the House Nancy Pelosi has vowed
that she will never fund that wall under
any circumstances the president promises
he's going to build one so that seems to
leave the White House with one option
declare a national emergency in order
the building of a wall on our southern
border that sounds like a pretty radical
solution but is it what turns out that
national emergencies happen all the time
and somehow very few of them receive any
attention at all in 1976 Congress passed
the national emergencies act that law
grants the president the power to
declare a state of emergency in response
to virtually anything if he thinks it's
necessary
national emergencies can be renewed
annually and routinely our Congress
could only block a state of emergency
with a two-thirds vote so it's a very
broad law and has been applied a lot
it began in 1979 President Jimmy Carter
declared a national emergency to keep
Iranian government property from
entering the United States that
emergency is still ongoing despite being
older than Alexandria Acacio Cortes for
example since that date American
presidents have declared no fewer than
58 national emergencies and 31 of them
are still ongoing right now the average
state of emergency in this country has
lasted for nine and a half years so what
are some of these emergencies well some
really were emergencies September 2001
for example President Bush announced a
state of emergency that gave the White
House greater authority to mobilize the
military called the National Guard and
perform other counter-terrorist actions
that emergency has been dutifully
renewed each of the past 18 years so
that was real we've also had a
decade-long national emergency to combat
the swine flu president Krampus declared
three national emergencies already bet
you didn't know that one of them
sanctioned those who use social media to
influence elections those desperately
macedonians another national emergency
condemned the government of Nicaraguan
President Daniel Ortega that was a
national emergency and yet another
ongoing national emergency punishes
anyone who works to quote undermine the
sovereignty of Lebanon
Lebanon you see the point here in
Washington protecting the sovereignty of
a faraway Middle Eastern country that
very few Americans will ever go to
qualifies as a national emergency
protecting our own country's sovereignty
is quote immoral and we're not
overstating that just this week for
freshman Democrats in the house
co-signed a letter demanding lower
funding for America's border enforcement
in other words it is virtuous to protect
others it is wrong to protect ourselves
and our own children what's the name for
that attitude well self-hatred would be
one should people who hate the country
be in charge of it